well today i'm indulging myself by
talking a little bit about a topic that
my own research is based on my challenge
for myself today is to try to link
together
the topics of the cosmic web
urban planning fingerprint recognition
and topological maps and if i can do all
that hopefully you'll understand a
little bit about how we go and try to
find our place in the large scale
structure in the universe let's do it
okay so the story starts with an image
that i saw taken from the international
space station which really caught my eye
because it looked so familiar so here's
what it is what you're seeing is an
image of the two cities of washington
and baltimore at night taken from the
international space station but what
struck me so much about this image was
how closely it resembles the images that
we make of galaxy clusters and the
cosmic web i should probably explain how
structure in the universe forms or at
least how we think it forms
since the universe is mostly composed of
dark matter and by dark matter i mean a
mysterious particle that we still
haven't found but we think is out there
in enormous quantities and only
interacts with itself and with other
matter through gravity and gravity
becomes the driving force no pun
intended of structure formation in the
universe because when you start off with
that initial smooth distribution of
matter what we think happened in the
early universe was that there were
actually tiny little
ripples in that distribution or quantum
fluctuations which led to some pockets
being slightly more dense than others
and if you then fast forward for 13.7
billion years and that gravity do its
thing those tiny over densities get
magnified by gravitational attraction
they pull in more material from around
them which then makes the gravitational
force larger and on and on and on so we
think of structure forming from little
things merging together to form bigger
things but if you look on the larger
picture what you actually see
is these huge big voids being created as
the matter drains away towards the sink
points and then you see filamentary
structure forming at the edges of these
voids and where those filaments
intersect you get the densest points
which we call nodes and it's at those
nodes that we think the biggest
structures in the universe galaxy
clusters form and you put it all
together you've got voids and sheets and
filaments and nodes and you've got what
we call the cosmic web now this is all
predicted in theory but we can also
simulate it very well in supercomputers
and there are many groups around the
world who specialize in doing this and
i'm very fortunate to be working with
some of them as well i don't do these
simulations myself but i use the outputs
from people who do run them can we also
just observe it when we look up at the
sky with telescopes so the problem with
telescopes is that they only capture
photons and we only get photons from the
things that glow in the dark now we call
dark matter dark it's not really dark
it's actually transparent it's
see-through because it doesn't emit
light nor does it cast a shadow so from
neither of those perspectives can we
capture it with our optical telescopes
there are other ways in which we can
find out it's there one of them is
gravitational lensing which was the
subject of my own phd thesis that lets
us see the invisible and make it visible
through understanding its gravitational
effect on light and when we do that yes
we start to see this very vague imprint
of the cosmic web most of my research to
date has been focused on those really
dense regions where the filaments
intersect the galaxy clusters so they're
rare objects but they do represent the
densest regions in the universe so
they're really interesting in terms of
understanding how structure formed but
also in understanding how galaxies
evolve in those environments but if we
want to understand how these clusters
are connected to the cosmic web we need
to look bigger and wider both in our
observations and in our simulations
and so this is where the project that
i'm working on right now comes in
we're trying to understand the
connection between really big galaxy
clusters and the cosmic web by tracing
the filamentary structure that connects
them now luckily there are lots of
methods that have been developed again i
haven't developed these but i happily
use them because that's how science
works we share our knowledge and we
share our techniques
and so we can take one of these
algorithms which is a topological
filament finder and we can apply it to
our data so when i say our data i want
to introduce a project called the 300
project
and this is a project that looks at
really detailed simulations of some of
the most massive clusters in a simulated
part of the universe you're now waiting
for me to make a connection to
washington and baltimore and that's
exactly what i'm going to do by
demonstrating on this image how we find
those filaments so i'm going to treat
this image just as i would a normal 2d
astronomical image and so i'm going to
pretend that all of those splunges of
light are say galaxies so the first
thing i would do on my astronomical
image is i would run some sort of
galaxy finder again there's many ways to
do this and the output can be different
in each time depending on how you set
your parameters
but when i ran one of those detection
algorithms on that i got this image okay
so we've got the background in sort of
white and orange and then if you zoom in
you would see that all of these green
splotches are actually individual little
ellipses
where this program this algorithm has
said okay i think there's a galaxy there
so once we have that collection of
points
we now
have to apply some sort of mathematical
some sort of topological algorithm to
connect those
and as i said there are many ways in
which you can do this there's lots of
different approaches
but the ones that we use works to find
the gradient of the density field so the
densest regions are right in the city
center and they get less dense as you go
out and if you fill up the whole image
with the whole volume you get a
continuous field where the density
varies it works in a similar way to how
you would find
fingerprints or how you would trace out
a root on a topological map by going
downhill and uphill through the density
gradient so where the density is highest
is in the close-packed city center and
where it sorts of tails off you get sort
of a downhill sort of feeling and so the
filaments then become the connecting
points between the critical points the
the highest density regions the lowest
density regions and maybe
as you might find on a mountain pass the
saddle points as well so when i run that
algorithm on our collection of galaxies
here i get this so this isn't real this
isn't physical this is a representation
a useful representation of the skeleton
of the structure that we see but it's
helpful to us
either in terms of tracing out
essentially the connections between
urban regions and even the roads that
you see here and it's helpful to us
tracing out the structure in the
outskirts of our galaxy clusters because
we always have to go back to the science
here what are we trying to figure out
we're trying to figure out how these
objects formed
does matter drain down first onto the
filaments and then onto the clusters
the galaxies that that fall into the
cluster do they have a different
experience coming in through the
filaments than falling straight in does
their gas get stripped off more readily
does it change how their star formation
properties are
so just as someone living in the suburbs
of a big city might have a different
lifestyle than someone living right
downtown the same goes for a galaxy so i
just thought i'd show you a concrete
example of how we go from individual
points whether those are dark matter
halos in our simulation or galaxies in
our observations and we turn that into a
density field that we can apply these
topological methods to so what i'm going
to show you here is a plate full of
skittles and i'm going to pour some warm
water on here and we're going to see the
color from these skittles diffuse
outwards
that looks amazing all right so here
we're trying to answer the question how
closely packed are these skittles or
these galaxies and what we've done here
is reproduce something called a
tessellation which allows us to
exactly split up the whole space into
individual cells each cell is kind of
owned by one of these skittles and the
property of each one of these colors is
that everything inside this red patch
here is closer to that red skittle than
to everything else it's not exact
because these are skittles but um you
get the idea and so this nice sharp line
here is exactly halfway between these
two points and what you can see now is
that we've got a series of cells which
when you put them together completely
covers that plate and it also gives us
an indication of how closely packed
those skittles are because where you've
got lots of small ones is where you've
got the densest regions
this now gives us a mathematical handle
on how the density is spread out over
the whole plane and that's what we can
then apply our topological algorithms to
what would be
like the great discovery what's the holy
grail of this research
the real thing that i'm trying to
understand is how the whole entire
lifetime of a galaxy taking into account
every environment that it's experienced
along the way has affected its evolution
have galaxies and clusters lost all of
their gas and stopped forming stars
because they've been sitting there for a
very long time
or have they had it removed before they
came in if they've had it removed is it
because they've just slammed into the
galaxy cluster and been stripped of all
their gas or have they bumbled along in
little groups like our own milky way and
andromeda
fallen down a filament and then
interacted with the cluster environment
in essence it's just trying to unravel
the entire past history of a galaxy when
with observations all we get is one
single snapshot of what it looks like to
us here and now
and for me that's
although i'm an observer that's where
the simulations come in where they're so
helpful and so useful because we can run
them forward and backwards in time we
can turn them around and look at them
from different directions we understand
not just the bits that go in the dark
but the dark matter as well
we might not get the physics right and
that's a big question to always keep in
mind
but by combining the observations with
the simulations we learn more about
both ways
across like this navigating carefully
and slowly to get through the narrows
however that's not what happens
the emo takes this corner wide to avoid
an oncoming ship this camera over here
is connected to this computer that does
all the image acquisition